you know the doctors sleep and the
shining are connected but how well you
don't need psychic abilities to figure
that one out today we're explaining the
many connections between the two films
including returning characters than
returning themes in the shining Stephen
King introduced us to Danny Torrance a
deeply strange little boy who has the
ability to see ghosts and communicate
telepathically
[Music]
after Danny and his parents move into
the Overlook Hotel for the winter a host
of ghosts starts slowly or not so slowly
driving his father mad they also take a
significant toll on Danny Danny and his
mother ultimately managed to escape the
mayhem but the haunted hotel cost Jack
Torrance his life most of dr. sleep
focuses on Danny as an adult he now
calls himself just dan and he finds that
as he gets older his mysterious shining
ability is often too much to bear like
his father before him he descends into
alcoholism as a way to numb his gift but
the ghosts of the past still manage to
catch up with him in the shining the
Overlook Hotel might as well be a
character both in the novel and in the
film version this formidable fortress is
horrific alia live with ghosts thanks to
the malevolent powers lurking within the
Overlook Hotel manages to claim Danny's
father Jack Torrance and it very nearly
claims Danny and his mom Wendy in King's
original novel the Overlook Hotel is
destroyed when it's faulty boiler
explodes meanwhile in Stanley Kubrick's
film adaptation of The Shining the hotel
is left standing and King's novel dr.
sleep the sight of the burndown Overlook
plays an important role but in the film
adaptation the structure is still there
exactly as it was left in the original
film they closed it down let it rot at
the end of the shining Danny and Wendy
Torrance leave the Overlook behind that
doesn't mean the hotel's ghostly
residents have left them behind
play with us in the novel dr. sleep we
learned that ghosts continue to torment
Danny after his ill-fated stay at the
Overlook
in fact they follow him and his mother
Wendy to their new apartment where Danny
becomes so afraid he refuses to go into
the bathroom and which ghosts are
haunting him well the dead woman in the
bathtub for one the same creep who
attacked Danny and terrified jack in the
shining
in fact she's such a powerful presence
her decomposing corpse leaves behind
physical residue in the bathroom of
Danny and Wendy's apartment though she's
the most terrifying and persistent ghost
to return from the Overlook she's not
the only spirit that follows poor Danny
the Torrance family wasn't entirely
alone in their fight against the
Overlook hotels supernatural forces
early on in the story Danny is
befriended by the overlooks cook dick
Halloran who reveals to Danny that they
both have telepathic abilities actually
he kind of brags about it my grandmother
at home the conversation but Kings book
and Kubrick's movie go in two very
different directions dick winds up
brutally killed in the movie but he
survives in the novel in fact he remains
friends with Wendy and Danny Torrance
after they managed to escape the hotel
dick also pops up in dr. sleep both in
the novel and in the movie the character
played by the late Scatman Crothers in
The Shining is now played by Carl Lumley
when Danny has difficulty shaking off
the ghosts of the Overlook dick pays him
a visit and helps him to
compartmentalize his trauma even after
dick dies he isn't entirely gone from
Dan Torrance's life that's the shining
for you without question the bond that
forms between Danny Torrance and dick
hallorann is one of the most important
relationships in the shining in fact
their psychic connection is so strong it
allows Danny to telepathically contact
dick from halfway across the country and
dr. sleep Dan develops a new psychic
connection with a young girl named a
Burris stone abre shining begins to
manifest when she's only a baby and it's
so strong she manages to establish a
connection with Dan by accident it's
Abra not Dan who first discovers the
dark forces
at work in doctors sleep and the two
psychics realized they must ultimately
work together to defeat some truly nasty
characters you imagine like me I was
called The Shining the Overlook is
essentially the central villain in the
shining the hotel's supernatural powers
prey on the Torrence family threatening
to drive them insane or worse but in dr.
sleep the main villains are a group of
psychic vampires called the true not who
are these jerks well they're a forceful
group of amoral nomads who prolong their
lives by feeding off the essence of
people who can shine they're led by a
devious figure known as Rose the Hat who
chooses the knots victims and finds new
members to initiate when the true not
become aware of Abra they hatch a plan
to track her down and consume all of her
psychic gifts in the novel dr. sleep we
learned that the true knot has a rather
strange connection to the Overlook Hotel
as Stephen King writes and dr. sleep The
Trews towns with colorful names like dry
bend Jerusalem's lot hoary and
Sidewinder or safe havens but they never
stayed in those places for long mostly
they were migratory so what's the
connection exactly well in the first
chapter of Kings novel The Shining we
learned that the Overlook was built in
the years 1907 to 1909 the closest town
is Sidewinder 40 miles east this means
that the true knot is inextricably tied
to the haunted hotel that changed Dan
Torrance's life forever check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one